what do all good horror films have in
common
you got some scares some suspense and a
whole lot of blood oh and also some big
bad guy bent on killing everyone in
sight but to get the job done right
those killers need some serious tools so
in honor of Halloween I'm taking a stab
at the top 7 weapons from horror movies
here's your Gore warning you know this
is gonna be violent number 7 Candyman
signature weapon a hook for a hand
whatever you do don't say his name five
times if you do he'll introduce you to
his handy hook that's jammed into the
bloody stump of his right arm and that's
not even all of it underneath that
fabulous winter coat he's hiding a torso
full of bees bees and what's worse he's
a romantic
number six Chucky's signature weapon
kitchen knife
well he's not cute but don't let the
fact that he's a dull fool you instead
of cuddling with you in bed he'd rather
go on a killing spree with his trusty
kitchen knife also he's nearly
invincible that dude's been burned shot
stabbed electrocuted exploded but guess
what he survived six movies and he's
going to be returning for another and
that's bad news for his upcoming
co-stars number five pinhead signature
weapon chains with hooks what might look
like an SNMP arty at first glance is
actually pretty terrifying pinhead has
demonic superpowers a passion for
torture and quite possibly acupuncture
he summons a whole bunch of hooks
attached to chains that dig into the
victims flesh then the chains are slowly
pulled in two different directions yeah
it's his horrible as it sounds number
four Jason Voorhees signature weapon
machete
Jason's kill count is well into the
hundreds he's nearly unstoppable and
loves to hide his beautiful looks behind
a hockey mask
Jason's also had a lot of changes over
the years I mean originally he like
drowned and technically he was his
mother that one was pretty weird but
then he became a supernatural serial
killer and then there was my personal
favorite Space Age cyborg you guys might
want to run the machetes his weapon of
choice and just one swing and he's on to
the next victim and there's more
sex-crazed teenagers where they came
from number three Leatherface signature
weapon chainsaw well this one was pretty
obvious wasn't it I mean it's right
there in the title the Texas Chainsaw
Massacre
the bloody apron and mask made of human
flesh doesn't have the same effect
without the unsettling sound of a
chainsaw
and to top it off the control and grace
that Leatherface had but such a brutal
weapon deserves the standing-room
ovation
don't you think beautiful number two
Michael Myers signature weapon butcher
knife listen Michael Myers has killed a
ton of people in a whole manner of
different ways but let's be clear he's a
slasher at heart even at six years old
he reached for the knife and killed his
15 year old sister that's hardcore
over a hundred kills later he still uses
this tool the same tool he's just more
efficient with it it's nothing out of
the ordinary you'll find it in any
kitchen but when you give it to a crazed
mental patient in a white mask that's
some scary [ __ ]
number one Freddy Krueger signature
weapon Claude glove what's worse than
one knife how about a hand made of
knives that's how you give every child
nightmares for the rest of their lives
please stop this
here's God Freddy's clawed gloves on the
top of this list because of its
originality
it's his homemade invention used to kill
children of Elm Street in fact without
the glove I don't know if Freddy would
have made the same impact the bathtub
scene is one of the most iconic from the
original movie but there were plenty of
kills that kept countless children up
all night long
afraid of falling asleep what did you
think about our list did we forget
something let us know and keep it here
at GameSpot universe for all of your
entertainment needs